the first ever dog has been cloned in
England and we've got a picture up the
cloned oxen
many Winnie now mal there's many way
that interview birth
cloned dog out of Britain very exciting
how do they do it
let's find out the so I'm biotech firm
to build his file sample
Winnie at Dorney the liquid nitrogen
as it was transported to South Korea
upon arrival
cells from the tissue sample were put
into eggs from a donor up
dog from the same breed creating a
cloned embryo
the embryo is that implanted into with
Erica dog and many
was born later by see section right
there there's a little a little science
Korea
the cloned dogs Welsh
back we knew this was coming close to a
hundred out about by the way
yeah to that same had the price texting
that you go out but glad you've got a
rescue and grab one for $10 back so that
the nation
yeah you could grab ten exactly they'll
give you clearly
your Big Dawg I 100 as a box recorder
too much I mean a dollar for clubs to
it because you're such a rescue me any
about you
you have had dogs that you love than
ever family I've had dogs I love in the
family but you have
the other cat animal inexplicably you
how are you a Catwoman
look oh then this I have to change my
notorious
Colorado levels in cats camping please
bring it
they're they're lovely creatures a if
they hate you there's probably a reason
you're saying that the at look there are
is now a little thing there's the world
shelters are overrun the killing dogs
across the country on a regular basis
like if you love dogs like this woman
doesn't she loves when Ian that's great
and went well when he's gonna die get
another dog go to winning
that think ken is made dogs you can
comfortably take care of
if you're a dog person like I I got a
dog three weeks after
a great start in the world he died at
four weeks after he died and I got it
because I
you know I want I was lonely but too I
like felt like I'm supposed to have dogs
I'm supposed to take care
yeah and I thought you know whatever in
my lane where ok he would want that
mostly McIlroy wanted forward
Russian going to be a customer but
although I just got
that was important and and so don't
clone friggin dog broader doused the
house that is great dogs go get them the
care right so we've already got the
breeders doing this in their
as he said they're putting down the
literally thousands about every day
whether they're also saying there is
there absolutely no not even close to a
guarantee that this dog is going to be
any
like the dog you remember yeah nothing
about it it
tissue but the way you treated the way
it's brought up that it it
how it will have different brain
chemistry registered
it's like they didn't even see multiple
said a
the first one was kinda like michael
keaton but then it gets a bad 800 yep
yep
up got the worst are but yes that is a
good point because
all about it we're thinking your gonna
clone a human then it wouldn't it
experiences at its life experiences my
dog is a is a rescue from New Orleans
after Katrina
I think she lived through some crazy
shit that now made her a sweet
and greater she is if I was to quote her
I have no reason to believe she would be
anything because but did just as a side
note did you look at twenty Labatt
with me that you could work Michael
Keaton Today Show I
your with michael keaton i was just
wondering yeah Michael he had my York
but then everything i mean that that
I think it's the logical next question
when you talk about doing this for the
animals if you
got a bit lost a child at a young age
and someone said hey we could give it
another shot at this kid
yeah would you do well is there are
ethnic difference in ethical difference
between doing this with
a animals and doing it with humans
because obviously the next step in this
and we're gonna it's gonna happen in our
lifetime will be humans yeltzin
course is different I love dogs but
their dog better soul band now you tell
me does not have sold
they have their tools are different
they're
to the long answer for very sore lol
about
pubs a good girl but but in bob kill a
cat klonopin kill the cake
hear it kill a cat in just ate Twitter's
of just oh my god that's so much worse
jump through a car window and at the
toes of Columbia
are you serious yet open
whose bones pretty bad was before I had
I'll
when you say right here and I'm gonna
happen that are big black cloud that
sorry I would rather
like a geyser yeah like she United okay
Academy I got a call that a I'm not a
clubber
a collab not gonna call me I don't know
that we fully
got everything I'm good at that time got
to get the car ready to rock and roll up
garage it wrong
it's wrong idea at the site people yeah
up